to make any comment now thank you what
about the city what what conversation
are you having with the bank of England
sir
do you have anything to say about what's
going on sir
are you planning to reverse the
announcement you made last Friday sir
what do you have to say about everything
that's been going on sir
just getting to my office now
thanks thank you very much sir thank you
a huge amount there from the chancellor
this morning uh our expectation is we're
not going to hear any specific response
from him to um the markets this morning
we did of course as I say hear from him
over the course of the weekend making
very clear they want to carry on with
the direction that they're going and I
think that is what has concerned as I
was saying some MPS I've spoken to one
person said that he should have
in more clear in his reaction to the
markets being spooked over the course of
the weekend and he said that there is a
small chance that quasi-courten's plan
works by accidents or maybe they are
geniuses but it's much more likely none
of this works and they've just been
experimenting with people's lives so
this is a Tory back bencher that has
been speaking to me another one um
saying that this is as bad as it was
under the worst days of Boris Johnson
there is definitely unease among some on
the Tory back benches were saying that
is certainly not everyone one person I'm
speaking to this morning said the MPS
don't need to panic he compared
Parliament to a blancmange saying that
there is often a wobble but that doesn't
actually mean anything serious but we
all know that Tory MPS if they do turn
against the prime minister in their
numbers can be very dangerous